what how would you not feel if males
exploited women the way how women
exploit males in the porn industry in
terms of this
all right so we're getting there now so
let's get there so we know that this man
at home is sitting down lonely he has no
sex he hasn't he's has no female
interaction but you're using that as
your tool to get money out of him okay
is that not exploitation i've i i only
watch porn from with men i don't know oh
say corn say corn corn yeah i only watch
corn with them
and made and females so how are we
exploiting because no i'm saying in
terms of like only fans in terms of like
fans um um chat obey i'm talking about
all these websites where they have girls
it's it's a website where girls sit down
in front of the cam and they're like
you're right i'm lonely guy four five
six yeah send me send me some dope i'll
show you my feet
like i'm your best friend i'm saying
this exploitation happens on what do you
mean is
is it exploitation or is it just an
exchange of services
can you hear that right okay so you
could argue that's what the tinder
swindler did
so i can't comment but he did get taken
to court right didn't he actually like
con them which is slightly different
yeah they just made his career
it's i would say it's slightly different
because he's met these individuals in
person he's built a rapport with them
he's he's actually thought allowed them
to think that they are getting to know
him as a person like if i was to meet
anybody
if we were to go out
there were some individuals that thought
they were engaged to this man they they
physically beam together okay okay but
so so the same way like the way you're
talking is literally how andrew tate
describes how the women need to talk to
the men
like i'm telling you word for word
basically and so just like i think it's
delusional of those men
to think that a woman like that is going
to take them seriously i think it's a
delusional of those women 100 average
average looking girls to think that a
multi-millionaire is going to take you
seriously is there not a difference when
there's a
um web screen
put in the way because the chats that we
were talking about that's kind of you're
paying for something virtually as
opposed to something with the tinder
swindler where that's in person you're
meeting these people and building no um
can i can i give you a stat so um
the results revealed that 23 of women
have engaged in a foodie foodie call on
an occasional basis with a number of
them believing it was socially
acceptable the second study analyzed 357
female participants and further
discovered that 33 of women would go on
a date purely for a free male right so
this happens like every day face to face
so you you like when you said you'll
make him wait
there's nothing stopping you from
actually having sex with him on day one
well it comes down to my own values i
know when whenever you you're ready
obviously
after a couple more dates after i've
spent my money on you after i often wait
hold on because
you potentially after the three months
could say you know what i actually don't
like you
but i've already invested in you for
three months well isn't that dating
what does every man want from a woman
that he's going to say we have to just
no no no i'm not saying that she's not
saying that you have to just give it up
he's talking about there's two different
types of girls right there's a type of
girl that makes you wait because it's
genuine and there's a girl that makes
you wait because she bet she's been ran
through and she's afraid of getting ran
through again and it's just completely
different to guys i think both are
justified to make somebody wait i think
it could be justified to a female
perspective but that's not how men view
it because they value chastity
they value purity and so it's like
you're you're the product right and it's
like you're upping the price that they
have to pay to get the product without
adding any extra value it's like you're
a lower value you might have learned a
few tricks
yes
you said it you said
about choice though isn't it it's as
simple as that you have a choice if you
don't want to stay with someone who is a
hoe go nah if you do exactly have fun
yeah but you're the is the deception so
you're saying i should be able to
deceive and you have the choice whether
or not you want to be deceived or not
doesn't it doesn't mean that the
deceiver is right to deceive what is
that
men deceive every diet exactly but does
it make it right that they deceive
everything that's not that's nice no it
doesn't make it wise
but a very small percentage of men even
have the option to deceive women again
one in three men under 30 they haven't
had sex in the past year
or are virgins
so that's what i'm saying the reason
women like say phrases like that is
because we're all sleeping with the same
guys it's a very small percentage of men
that can even get girls
yeah i
i really find that shocking i thought
everybody could get a girl
you just go to some of them clubs on a
friday saturday night they're out there
well those are the guys that cannot
those are the guys that can afford to
make it to the club just outside don't
even need to go in
the tube
i i think else i'll give it i see i
think you're where where are these women
giving it out
can you name an exact time on location
i'm gonna hook you up i'm gonna hook you
up because even the most like out there
man he still has to go through like
hoodles and hoops to play with women
even even that 20 guy still has to be on
point and do things right and be in the
right place at the right time say the
right things be the right physique um
take her to the right place say the
right things to her friends there's a
lot of things that are so hard for you
guys it is so hard because you don't
have no expectations you could just come
with your
what do women have to do to get sex we
just have to exist
i'm not saying it's your fault but i'm
saying like i empathize with men because
it's a lot harder for them to even feel
like desired they have to go through all
of this work to even have girls
interested in them where we just exist
we have such a guard up of what guys we
do go around but but women go after the
bad guys and then complain
yeah
so you've got that
my thing is right so with this hypergamy
stuff is that
these women a lot of these women will
get with the key players these are the
guys that you know
when you dance there's certain guys that
just smash everyone in it they take
advantage of the new girls they tap
everyone so those girls they go with
that guy
and then now they've learned their
lessons they've dated mr toxic he did
this that this that he's telling me i'm
like uh-huh uh-huh
and then they're like oh you know i want
to take it but it's slow with you
listen listen i was you know i was young
then i just you know you need to really
and i and i understand it because you
know i dismiss those women but
do you understand it though really i do
i do understand because for a man
the advantage we have that's never
spoken of we have the advantage of
experience
like yeah we get screwed over and it's a
hustle but
i i get i have infinite a lot of time to
figure it out women don't really have
that much time in it so for me past a
certain age past 27 when i've seen
enough i'm like oh snap i really get
like
um
for me every year there is a new cohort
of
young women who think they're grown
coming in and it's easy
it's it's extremely yo you're a predator
no it's not even pretty they all think
they're like you know i'm i'm 21 i'm
graduate from uni i know it bro listen
there's four of us here that specialize
in these women exactly like you i know
where to take you i know what to say i
know what you think of yourself
and it happens so that's the advantages
we have in it that
every man is like born like an rpg
character in it we all start on level
one everyone even the coolest guy in
leonardo dicaprio do you mean as in